hey everyone it's joanna here so today
we are back for another workout
challenge this time it's going to be a
lunch and squat challenge and our goal
is to hit 500 reps
this challenge is low impact that means
it is safer on your knees and we will be
going through 10 different squat and
lunge variations so let's get our lower
body ready and let's fill the burn
together
[Music]
i have hazli here with me to get us
through this challenge together okay so
before we start this challenge let us
make sure that we know how to perform a
proper squat and a proper lunge so stand
in a neutral position what i mean by
that is making sure that your feet are
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward okay so not too wide or
not too narrow always making sure that
your feet are shoulder width apart with
your toes pointed forward and as you
squat i want you to think of pushing
your butt back first so i'm going to
show it from a side angle and hussy will
be showing it from the front angle okay
so making sure they are pushing your
butt back
and
push up using the strength from your
heels okay so do not tiptoe again squat
down and as you push up
push from your heels so if you find
yourself doing this this is wrong this
is not a squat okay remember chest up
squat down and push back okay so i want
you to make sure that your pro you're
doing a proper squat in order to get the
maximum benefit from this workout all
right now let's get into lunges okay
same thing with lunges
stand shoulder width apart with your
toes pointed forward all right and as
you take a lunge forward step forward
lunge down
keeping your body in a straight line
chest up and push back okay so from a
side angle remember you want to always
make sure that your chest are upright
okay so step forward chest up do not
lean forward
and push back up okay now change the
other side step forward
and push up all right so always remember
when i say stand in a neutral position
that means stand shoulder width apart
toes pointed forward are we ready
okay
10 workouts 10 exercises
50 repetitions each okay so it's going
to be a variation of squats and lunges
as well all right so let's start with
the first squat variation which is going
to be a prisoner squat
all right with a twist
okay so every rep is when you squat down
are we ready hus
let's go arms up
stand shoulder width apart if you want
to just slightly wider remember toes
pointer forward hands up let's go down
and twist good job twist the opposite
side
and try to get your elbows to tap your
knee
okay if you can't that's okay just a
slight twist
and feel the work on your core as well
remember chest up
stand tall
and squat
low
okay push your butt back
squeeze
good job
doing good
down
twist
down
and squeeze
nice
first exercise
50 reps
all right
stay with us we're going to get through
this together
and you will end this workout feeling
really strong
and because it's low impact
no jumping at all
down and twist
another tip is to always remember
to pace
your breathing okay
taste your breathing
and breathe out
as you twist there you go
nice
hands up
squat down
we are almost there okay
ten more reps
down
twist
good job
if your legs are absolutely burning what
you can do
is stand up
shake it out and join me back in this
workout when you're ready twist
two more twist
one more
and shake it off well done
that's a really good way to kick start
this challenge as well okay the next one
is going to be a forward and back lunge
okay so let's face this with us okay so
that we have more space so
with forward and back lunge let's start
on our left leg to begin with okay so
what i want to do is take a white step
forward lunge down making sure both legs
are in a 90 degree position
push up tap
and lunge
back okay
so that's two reps okay so we'll be
doing 25 reps on one leg and 25 reps on
the other side are we ready
let's go
starting on your left side okay
forward lunge tap
back
good job remember stand tall
drive your knees down towards the floor
keeping a 90 degree
bent in your knees okay
there you go
once you find your rhythm
keep to that rhythm
tap forward
and down
so you should feel the work on your
right
leg
whoa feeling the burn on your quads your
glutes
as well as on your hamstrings
keep going we have five more reps
that's three more
one more
and shake it out good job
okay
are we ready to switch sides okay
so now working on your right leg and you
should feel the work on your left side
okay are we ready haas let's go right
side forward
tap
back
there you go
good job remember take it one step at a
time
find a focal point okay
look forward
find your balance
brace your core
do you feel the work on your left thighs
and your left glutes
that's what we want okay that burn right
there
down
and forward
good job we are almost there
it's going really fast isn't it down
at three more
and last one okay shake it out okay
just like this we have done 100
repetitions okay next
back to squats okay this time i want you
to stand wider than shoulder width apart
with your toes pointed out so
for this squat variation you will feel
it more on your inner thighs as well as
your outer glutes okay it's going to be
a play touchdown and the reason why i
want you to tap the floor is to make
sure that you're squatting low enough
okay are we ready stand wide if you have
longer legs then step wider okay all
right step wide hose points at all are
we ready let's go only 50 reps go tap
changing arms okay making sure you're
standing tall
tap and reach as you can see
we're still looking forward our chest is
still upright okay
no slouching down this is wrong okay
tap
and look forward
chest up
push
feel the work
on your inner thighs
and your outer
glutes
good job
working on all
different
muscles
tap
tap okay
i want you to squat low so remember in
order to touch the floor you have to
squat low and it's not about bending
from your waist
tap
good job we're almost
there
tap
10 more reps let's go team we're strong
i'm feeling the burn
i know
but we're going to stay together and
push through to the end that's one more
and up
shake it out okay
oh my gosh
just pat your legs
just release that tension all right
okay
this next exercise is actually hazy
favorite okay
it's a love-hate relationship it's
called 3d lunge all right what that
means is that we'll be lunging forward
diagonally diagonally and to the side
and we will be pulsing throughout the
lunge so let me just show you first okay
starting on your left leg forward pulse
and out
that's three reps okay so i'm going to
be nice that's three reps and then we
will change
on the other side house
pulse and back up okay
50 reps 25 on each side are we ready
let's go
3d lunge
and go
remember do not step back
pulse it out
back
change the other side
[Music]
and back good job
there you go you're getting the rhythm
back
[Music]
remember if you're struggling to find
your balance
take it one
lunge at a time okay
push
push and back
good job
oh that pulse
oh
i can feel my quads on this
one back
halfway there
[Music]
okay so remember
rotate
according
to
the angle diagonal and to the side and
back up
forward
diagonal
side
up
nice
wide step okay
back
last
six more on each side
back
[Music]
back one more come on
two
three and ah
oh my gosh
i know
and that's what i love about this
challenge is that we're targeting our
quads and our glutes as well as our
hamstrings from all different angles
okay forward back as well as diagonally
and to the side as well all right
back to squat
okay so
giving your legs a short break
next is going to be a narrow to a white
squat so
for a narrow squad what i want to do is
step close together okay
with still with your toes pointed
forward same thing push back
push up using your heels step wide
down and up okay so every squat is one
rep are we ready alternating between
left and right okay let's go squat down
up
wide and push
narrow
and step out
and narrow okay so it's a narrow
to a white squat
and just allow your arms
to follow
the rhythm
good job
there you
go
this is like a short break isn't it
after
that challenging
lunch pulses
up
narrow
white
okay do not
compensate on your form right now okay
we are halfway through the workout
stay strong
make every rep a quality wrap
down
wide
narrow
good job
take a white step out
and really keep your feet close together
and remember
breathe out
as you come up
okay
pace your breathing
it really helps you to go further
in your workout
down
there you go in
two more narrow
one more
and oh my god
if you're doing this with a partner give
them a high five because you're halfway
through your workout okay if you need to
take a short break
pause this video right now wipe your
thread keep yourself hydrated we have
another
250 repetitions all right
okay
so
if you have taken a break welcome back
next workout is going to be a fight
lunch and a kick so what i'm going to do
is find some space step on the edge of
your mat or your space and what i'm
going to do is take a white step to the
side
lunge
with your
knees pointed forward and as you come up
if you want to tap and kick forward okay
so 25 on each side before we change on
to the other leg are we ready so let's
really
put some power into the kicks let's go
side lunge
okay okay lunge
kick
good job
again
it's all about
raising your call
finding your balance
and using the strength from your leg
to help you
with
the lunge and the kick
nice job
high kick
good
there you go strong
forward kick
let me hear some noise wow
good
looking strong
push your arms back as you kick forward
that's going to help you with the kick
okay
arms back
that's three more
two more
one more and kick
oh my gosh
okay
as you know we have two legs so now
let's shuffle a little bit on this side
all right
we're going to work on our right side
okay ready let's go step out
and kick
good job
some of you
might find that you struggle to balance
on the other legs okay
that's okay
try your best
keep it up
use
the momentum
from your arms to help you as well
up
push your arms back up
and kick
good job
high kicks
10 more reps
[Music]
looking like a fighter
nice
kick
push
two more
one more
and
okay
give your legs a short break
all right
this next workout honestly it's going to
be a slight challenge that's because we
want to stay in a low squat throughout
the entire workout okay so it's going to
be a
lateral squat walk all right
husband is like what on earth are we
doing look at him he's sweaty
i'm sweaty as well and i hope all of you
at home are feeling the same okay let us
know in the comments below how you're
feeling
oh struggling to catch my breath
let's finish this all right with lateral
squat walk okay let's start on
this side of your space okay what i'm
going to do is start in a low squat
position
walk to the left two steps walk to the
right
two steps and if you need a break come
back up okay so the whole goal is to
keep a low squat throughout the entire
workout are we ready let's stay low
let's go squat down
one
two
three
four if you need a break then up
go down
there you go
two steps to the right and two steps to
the left if not let's continue okay
if you want more burn let's go stay low
zap it out
[Music]
doing good
looking great i know push your butt back
okay
maintaining
a low squat position
if at all you feel that you know what
joanna my legs are totally on fire i
need a short break then by all means and
ah okay continue
that was a short two seconds break just
for husband you know
you know what i mean
really challenging him
let's go 10 more reps
10 more steps
you're almost there
stay with me
that's the burn that we want
and that's how we grow and progress and
ah
well done
okay
all right shake it out okay
catch your breath breathe in breathe out
okay
this next workout is going to be a
combination of lunges with squats all
right this is actually my favorite it's
going to be a cutsy lunge so what i want
to do is point your toes slightly to an
angle okay
curtsy lunge crossover
all right but still making sure your
chest is facing forward and step out
to a sumo squat
all right got that
so
curtsy
and sumo right ready let's go curtsy
step out
and wide
nice there you go
same thing working on one side
25 reps before we switch
to the other leg okay
white really feel the stretch on your
inner thighs
as you step wide okay
and
as you get into a cut lunge it's also to
focus on your outer glutes as well
pretty
try to get your knees to tap the floor
if you can
do not rest
curtsy
white
curtsy
white and let's end in a courtesy
position
okay check it out
check it out
heart rate is going high
we're burning calories
we're getting our lower body really
strong and you should feel your legs
really tight right now okay all right
let's talk let's go right side curtsy
twist
and
white
okay twist
wide good job so you can either keep
your arms on your waist or just
forward
wide
push it back
and step wide
good
job it down
if i'm not talking
you know i'm really feeling this workout
down
out five more reps
now three more
and let's end
in a curtsy
and up
okay
all right house can you believe it we
have done 400 repetitions that means we
only have two exercises left okay so
next is going to be a lunge with a new
driver same thing let's start on our
left side so
you know what let's face this way
okay
and what i'm going to do is take a
reverse lunge with
your knees up okay
reverse lunge and as you come up
drive your knees up tap and back all
right are we ready working on your left
side to begin with raise your core final
balance look straight at one focal point
do not shift your head okay you're going
to really lose balance if you do that
all right let's go back
up
back
up there you go
reverse lunge
with a knee driver
good as high as you can
really push your knees up
and
swing
your arm back
as you drive your knee up
good job
strong knees
just like in a kickboxing class okay
push
up
[Music]
good job
keep going
pushing through the front
foot
that's one more
losing my balance right there one more
and shake it off
okay
all right
the other leg okay now let's just
switch over
now right leg back and drive your knee
up
are we ready remember find your focal
point all right and find your rhythm
let's go
lunge back
knee up
good job
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
good job
strongly
[Music]
ten more reps
let's go
we're almost there
[Music]
five more okay
one
two
three
four
one more five and ah
oh my gosh well
good news you're almost at the end of
your workout
this last 50 reps
it's going to be pretty much stationary
okay
husley's like what on earth are we doing
guys
we don't practice our workout we just
try to have fun together and
let us you know get through this
together and we want you to enjoy this
workout with us as well okay
last 50 reps is going to be a squat
pulse that means we'll be staying low
and we'll be passing throughout the 50
reps are we ready
i'm struggling to catch my breath let's
go
oh i can hear that let's go strong
one two down one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten small pauses
two three four five six
seven eight nine twenty stay low
two three four
five six seven eight nine thirty twenty
more
two
three four five six seven eight nine
fourteen let's count down together okay
three
four five six seven eight nine fifty oh
okay oh my gosh
oh it's raining in here
oh
if you're doing this with a partner you
know what give them a high five tell
them what an amazing job they have done
thank you so much haas
thank you so much for motivating us and
getting through this entire 500 squad
and lunch challenge with us
okay
before we go anywhere let's end with a
quick cooldown to just stretch out on
our legs okay we have done a lot of work
on our legs so
let's just face forward okay what i want
to do is take a wide step forward just
like in a lunge position but now rest
your knees on the floor all right and
just
drive your leg forward push forward
feel the stretch on your right hip
flexor and just reach up
good job
just take this time to breathe
bring your heart rate down
and really breathe into the stretch
okay
a lot of work on our hip flexor and
basically our entire
leg okay and now just twist
and
look as far back as you can
feel the stretch on your back
when it comes to doing lunges and squats
you don't realize that your core is
actually doing a lot of work in order to
stabilize your entire body
therefore it's really important for us
to stretch
our back and our core as well
and now straighten the front leg
feel the stretch on your hamstrings okay
i have tight hamstrings so i'm just
going to go as slow as i can
for those of you with tighter hamstrings
you can just maintain a higher position
for those of you are extremely flexible
you can go all the way down okay so
stretch according to your ability
to stretch the hamstrings
[Music]
and now
slowly change the other side okay
right leg forward or the other leg and
same thing what i want to do is push
your body weight forward and you should
feel the stretch on this part okay your
hip flexors reach up
look straight up
[Music]
and breathe
okay inhale all the good energy to
kick-start your day or to end your day
skip in
and now twist
look as far back as you can
really feel the stress on your back
remember to keep your back
upright okay do not slouch
[Music]
and release straighten the front leg
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
point your front toes
[Music]
good job and now slowly come back into a
standing position
all right
and just take a wide step
what i want to do is just reach down
touch the floor okay
again feel the stretch on the hamstrings
and now link both arms together this is
actually my favorite and just sway your
body to the left and to the right
allow momentum
to just
drive your body to the left and right
and feel the stretch on your hamstrings
okay
job
and now come back into center
bring your feet together
slowly come back up
and let's just stretch our quads okay
if you struggle to find your balance you
can just hold on to the wall
okay stretch on your quads if not just
reach out arms out
really bring
your heels to touch your butt
good job
[Music]
breathe
and release
change
okay
reach out stand tall
again if you're struggling you can
always hold on to something
and release okay three deep breaths okay
ah let's go breathe in
reach stretch and out
again second
in
and out
and last one
in
and a really loud style ready huss go ah
very very well done again give your
partner a high five
he did amazing okay and he looked
amazing well done
that was your 500th squad and lunch
challenge my legs are on fire right now
let me know in the comments below how
you felt okay if you enjoyed this
workout be sure to give this video a
thumbs up check out a lot more workout
challenges on my youtube channel and
don't forget to also hit the subscribe
button if you haven't yet done it and i
will see you in my next workout all the
best